il nous sommes préparés pour les
éventualités à des n'importe où via les
menaces cyber les cyber-menaces pendant
la dernière élection fédérale il ya
quatre ans la crainte d'une attaque
contre notre processus électoral par des
puissances étrangères ne nous effleurer
pas vraiment l'esprit mais disons que
les temps ont bien changé et nos voisins
du sud le savent mieux que quiconque
alors jeff les élections ça se passe pas
comme ça se passait avant gracieuseté
l'ingérence étrangère
on pense tout de suite aux russes et à
l'élection présidentielle américaine en
2016 mais concrètement comment ça s'est
opéré comment les russes ont fait donc
une entreprise à saint petersburg états
unis pendant la campagne de 2007
c'est très simple c'est savoir gros ça
va super compliqué mais en fait ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est simple mais c'est
dieu
on veut du concret des fausses pages des
faux comptes sur instagram facebook mais
pour toutes sortes de causes politiques
donc ici on est des fausses pages pour
les droits des noirs aux états unis la
brutalité policière mais aussi en sports
ou politiques dont franche des deux
côtés
même clivage social les clivages sont
déjà là ce qu'on a tenté de faire c'est
d'aller jouer dans cette brèche mais les
larges donc alimenter l'animosité sur
des réseaux sociaux avec sa tante et de
mobiliser les gens lorsque jeff ce que
tu montres la partie apparente de
liesberg et finalement il ya d'autres
choses qui se passent en dessous si on
veut de façon beaucoup plus masqué on
pense aux cyberpiratage société une
stratégie des russes tout à fait il ya
eu piratage des courriels du parti
démocrate
pendant l'élection les courriels ont été
futé par les pirates ça c'est sûr
wikileaks
les chaleurs wikileaks j'ai vu la même
chose pendant l'élection présidentielle
française
est ce qu'on est macronix dont tu es
venu pirates qui ont tenté pas la même
chose donc de dévoiler des courriels
embarrassants pour le candidat à la
présidentielle emmanuel macron par
contre en france les médias n'ont pas
mordu à la pop dont il y avait une sorte
d'entente pour dire on ne va pas couvrir
des courriels des fuites de courriels
dont on ne connaît pas la provenance
avec la cie ont placé dans le contexte
de l'élection fédérale canadienne
actuelle jusqu'à quel point le canada
peut aussi être une cible des russes par
exemple ou d'autres intérêts ailleurs
dans le monde pour effectuer de
l'ingérence ça pourrait être possible au
canada quand même des des adversaires en
géostratégie politiques des pays comme
la chine l'iran la russie qui sont pas
des ennemis du canada mais disons que
les relations sont un peu plus tendue en
ce moment il des campagnes comme ça
c'est relativement simple et
relativement peu coûteux à faire les
clivages sociaux on peut les exploiter
au canada tout à fait les plus belles
chaussures non canada l'immigration les
changements climatiques les pipelines
pouvait on l'a vu avec mon collègue et
roberto vin chaud de la civis et on a
regardé et wit associés à des faux
comptes
irani cette fois ci qui s'est amplifiée
des messages au canada par rapport à
l'immigration et au pipeline
le canada est possible aussi jutras
russe que les etats-unis mais aussi faut
se rappeler qu'il ya une élection
l'année prochaine aux etats-unis en 2020
est ce que ça pourrait servir comme
feuille de route comme madame aratoires
comme un cobaye
ces prêts servaient comme laboratoire
pour tester des nouvelles façons de
faire dérailler une élection on le sait
pas mais les institutions peuvent être
piratés donc que ce soit élections
canada ça soit les ministères où que ce
soit les partis
selon un sondage national effectué en
février
soixante pour cent des citoyens sont
d'avis qu'un gouvernement étranger va
tenter d'influencer la campagne
électorale fédérale
et maintenant que la campagne est lancée
on voulait tâter le pouls de la
population
le canada pour être sublime way
certainement au canada j'ai l'impression
que normalement c'est moins pire qu'aux
états unis lequel j'ai pas très peur
mais bouclé les gouvernants sont
conscients de ce qu'ils en font assez
pour nous protégeons question j'espère
qu'ils sont conscients qu'ils planifient
faire quelque chose d'un contre-sort ses
craintes jusqu'à quel point elles sont
justifiées
on est allé demander l'avis de
jean-philippe décarie mathieu un expert
en cybersécurité au commissionnaire du
québec une entreprise spécialisée dans
la sécurité en ligne
est ce que vous êtes déjà fait à l'idée
d'après ce qu'on vaut celle qui peut y
avoir l'ingérence étrangère au cours de
la campagne actuelle peut certainement
la voix enrouée son possibilité [ __ ]
je pense que ce soit un état de fait
auquel les démocraties libérales
occidentales doivent faire face
maintenant et des acteurs y groupe en
russie en chine en iran corée du nord
dans différents pays qui existent dont
le but premier est justement faire de
l'ingérence de miner la confiance les
gens ont dans le système démocratique
certaines possibilités et si le canada
n'est pas une cible privilégiée pour les
acteurs à l'étranger qui voudraient
déstabiliser les choses en occident on
peut se servir du canada comme tu es
sont me tester de nouvelles tactiques
d'une belle technique 2003 sept jours
quand on est aux étrangers qui est
opposé à nos valeurs ou du moins aux
intérêts nationaux
on peut certainement de ce soit comme
comme cette élection la com com phase de
test sur vous parlons maintenant des
policiers de nos élus selon vous jusqu'à
quel point ils sont conscients du
problème des risques qui planent au
dessus de notre démocratie
je pense qu'ils sont conscientisés au
problème je ne sais pas quel point ils
saisissent la portée et au organisés qui
ont les ressources les moyens le
savoir-faire pour femmes ingérence comme
ça il y en a plus y en a qui disent
depuis longtemps je pense notamment la
chine
en 2003 il y avait six mille un curseur
perron péron et articles pour justement
faire d'ingérence étrangère 2000 trou
même pas imaginer son renvoi combien
maintenant pignon commandes d'un
dernières années à se réveiller la tuer
l'autre un groupe rails on est
extrêmement bon donc si on voulait
trouver une façon de faire le pauvre se
prémunir face à de telles attaques l'un
d'eux telle ingérence qu'est ce qu'on
devrait faire en tout premier lieu la
priorité ça serait quoi pour que notre
système soit blindés ben faut se sortir
de la tête qu'un système pas être blindé
programme au départ c'est un possible
risque surtout en cybersécurité là ça
n'existe pas tout est à 4 des coupons et
de compromis c'est très dur à dieu
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais d'abbas
qu'on recommence à leforest aucun d'eux
mais c'est vraiment on est vraiment tort
le tube ou qu'on a on aura encore une
quinzaine d'années à reprendre sur
certains acteurs malicieux étrangers et
certains pays c'est ça qui m'inquiète en
fait c'est ça va pas ça continue
d'arriver d'ingérence puis ça va se
décliner différentes manières
différentes tactiques
puis on devrait enfin merci l'ancien